Erstmal deine Videobearbeitung ist toll, sehr beeindruckend, benutzt wohl
Final Cut Pro oder irgendwas anderes kreatives
Ziemlich cool, ein paar meiner Freunde machen auch sowas
und ich finde es immer wieder toll
Ich bin ganz verwirrt davon... seine erste Frage war... der Charakter
Ich denke kindisch ist ein gutes Wort für
Lilly, sie ist sehr kinidisch und unreif
Ich habe den Charakter so lange gespielt, dass ich ihn auch
entwickeln kann und ihn auch ein bisschen reifer machen konnte
In der letzten Staffel, die gerade in Deutschland läuft
oder schon gelaufen ist, bin mir nicht sicher
sieht man wirklich wie die Charaktere mit denen einige
vielleicht zusammen aufgewachsen sind auch reifer werden
Sie sind im letzten Jahr der High School, haben feste Freunde,
Jobs und gehen aufs College und sie benehmen sich reifer
Und sie entfernen sich von ihrem Image, am Anfang war Hannah Montana ein Skatergirl
Sie trug diese abgeflippten Klamotten und jetzt ist sie viel reifer.
Ich erinnere mich, dass ich mal zur Garderobe ging
und der Produzent und der Kostümdesigner saßen da
Sie sahen mich und sagten: "Stop! Wir lieben was du
trägst!" UNd ich habe meine ganz normalen Klamotten getragen
Und sie meinten: "Wir brauchen genau deinen Style für Lilly."
Also in der letzten Staffel haben sie so ziemlich
meinen Style genommen und den Charakter geschmückt
aufgerissene Jeans, coole Schuhe, ich denke das ist mein Style
Aber ich denke am Anfang war's ein bisschen kindisch, aber das war ich!
In der letzten Staffel habe ich ein 18-Jähriges Mädchen gespielt, ich hatte nichts dagegen
Und ich Denke Disney ist familienfreundlich, und ich
habe keine Probleme solche Rollen zu spielen
Auch wenn ich gerne Final Destination oder Doom machen würde
Das würde Spaß machen, ich hatte noch nicht die
Chance ein Gothic-Girl in einem Horrorfilm zu spielen
Ich will definitiv mehr verschiedene Rollen spielen, egal welches Genre
Aber nicht weil ich ein Image los werden will
sondern weil ich bereit bin neues auszuprobieren.
Sehen wir uns deine zweite Frage an...
Ich mag dein Shirt
Das ist eine gute Frage, Schule is sehr wichtig für mich, mein
ganzes Leben lang war mein Traum ins College zu gehen
Zum Glück war ich trotz Hannah Montana in der Lage meine Private High
School zu besuchen, sie war nur eine Stunde vom Dreh weg
Manchmal wurd es schwierig, weil ich 3 Wochen eines Monats nicht in
der Schule war, weil wir 3 Wochen an der Show arbeiteten
Ich war nur ab und zu eine Woche in der Schule,
und musste meine Hausaufgaben zwischen Proben und Shootings machen
Besonders im Junior Year, dem härtstem Jahr der
High School hatte ich total viele Aufgaben
Ich musste es alles zu Hause machen bevor wir an der
Show arbeiteten, und musste es faxen, schicken oder persönlich übergeben
Es war total anstrengend
Ich habe mich entschieden zu einem unabhängigem Bildungsprogramm zu wechseln
wo ich nur eine Lehrerin hatte, es war toll
Sie arbeitet jetzt übrigens mit einer YouTube Sensation
die ein Lady Gaga Cover gemacht hat
Sie ist unglaublig, sie hat mir sehr im letzten Jahr der High School geholfen
Ich konnte die Kurse machen die ich wollte,
wann ich wollte, total stressfrei und effektiver
Aber ich hatte eine normale High School Erfahrung, was toll ist
Ich finde die Schule sehr wichtig und will nächstes Jahr ins College
Dieses Jahr kann ich nicht weil ich hier bin, ich reise zu viel momentan
Das College ist sehr anders und ich will auch wirklich
da sein und nicht wieder meine Aufgaben dort hinschicken
Ich bewundere Leute wie Emma Watson, die das College nebenbei machen können
Ich wurde schon angenommen im College, ich muss nur noch warten
Gute Fragen! Genießt die Zeit in der Schule, Schule ist wichtig!